[Music]
straight ahead on lawn crime daily
never before seen body camera footage of
the moments leading up to dante wright's
death
deontay wright
dante dante right you can't tell you're
under arrest aren't they and a verdict
handed down in a polarizing case as tv
star jessie smalled faces possible
prison time plus a new ruling on
abortion laws in texas we're breaking
down the supreme court ruling and later
the murdoch murder mystery what new
charges the disgraced south carolina
attorney now faces law and crime daily
covering court cases from coast to
[Music]
coast welcome everyone to law and crime
daily i'm brian buckmeyer along with
terry austin strong testimony brings
week one of kim potter's trial to a
close as we hear from an officer who was
there at the time of the shooting
his never before seen body camera
footage shows what happened in the
moments after kim potter shot dante
wright
we're going to need additional units
to noble in 63rd
[Music]
potter an ex-minnesota police officer
faces first and second-degree
manslaughter charges in the death of
20-year-olds wright friday's testimony
detailed the april 11 traffic stop when
wright was pulled over officers then
attempted to take him into custody for
an arrest warrant potter shot right in
the chest he died as a result of the
injuries potter maintains she
accidentally grabbed her gun instead of
a taser on friday major michael johnson
took the stand where the defense pressed
him on police procedure
and then when she after she said she
shot him she
was really having a difficult time
saying oh my god oh my god oh my god
correct yes
and you're concerned about her correct
yes
and then
she said oh my god oh my god i'm going
to go to prison
do you remember saying that yes
and
lucky said
according to the video
no you're not no you're not then you
said kim
the guy that was trying to take off with
me in the car
you agree you said that right yes
and if he had taken off with you
in that car halfway what would have
happened to you
do you what would you think would be the
worst that would happen probably dragged
dragged and what
injured seriously injured maybe even
dead right yes
and if that were the case
with an officer
in your position
with kim
officer potter trying to stop him from
resisting with you and resisting lucky
would it be fair for that officer to use
a firearm to stop him by state statute
yes
and while the prosecution's questioning
may have started smoothly its redirect
was riddled with objections
so what
miss potter used here was deadly force
yes and when you use deadly force you
have to consider surroundings
yes
and when you
the objection is sustained
no leading questions please i will
rephrase when you use deadly force
do you need to consider
surroundings
yes
and do you need to know whether you
could shoot another police officer
or another person
yes
could officer potter
in using a firearm have shot
you
possible
could
[Music]
the objection is sustained
joining us today is l.a county deputy
public defender phillip duvet and terry
austin philip the defense got officer
johnson to say that by statute potter
was allowed to shoot her gun is this the
first brick in the road to an acquittal
oh my goodness this is the first step
toward reasonable doubt for officer
potter
often times the
police policies and procedure
manual are much narrower than what the
law allows for
and defenses are very fluid throughout a
trial and they can develop during
opening statement during testimony and
even in closing argument so even though
the defense may have been this was an
accident by all accounts according to
this uh prosecution expert slash witness
uh kim potter's behavior was completely
lawful it's significant because the
first degree manslaughter charge is
premised upon reckless handling of a
firearm and if if the discharge was in
fact lawful you do not have recklessness
and the standard is that she created an
unjustifiable and substantial risk of
great bodily injury or death but if it
was lawful by statute that's reasonable
doubt make sense terry the defense seems
to be pushing the theory that potter
shot right to save the life of a fellow
officer how does that work with the
manslaughter charges well you know it's
interesting philip is right the defense
is changing its case as the evidence
come comes in basically they were saying
well this is an accident now they're
saying it was the appropriate use of
force whether she was using her taser or
her gun because they're trying to say
that she was protecting officer
johnson's life so i think what the
prosecution has to do now is come back
and say look
she shouldn't have been using a taser or
a gun it was dangerous she was you know
infringing on the life of others
possibly and so i think it's going to be
a hard task for the prosecution at this
point yeah there's definitely a day that
i think the defense made some headway in
their case
thank you both the first week gave us
gripping testimony from first responders
but also those closest to donte wright
long crime daily sierra gillette
gillespie spoke with wright's family
attorney who explains how the family is
coping amidst the high profile case
ryan emotions are running high in
minnesota as the family of dante wright
prepares for their first holiday season
without him just seven months removed
from his death the wright family
attorney jeff storms tells me it's an
emotional time to begin a trial this is
when you're hugging your loved ones at
thanksgiving
or christmas
and you know he was by all accounts uh
you know sort of the the class clown
right for the family he was someone uh
you know had a big smile could make the
family laugh for all of them
you know it's left a huge
huge hole in the shadow of this trial
looms the george floyd and derek chauvin
case philonous floyd and brandon
williams came to give support to dante
wright's family
you know those families got to know each
other really well because dante was
killed in the middle of that trial but
the potter trial includes testimony from
one key witness the chauvin trial lack
it was the worst day of my life the one
piece of testimony we didn't get to hear
in that case was
a parent losing a child just the the
loss of a child to listen to a mother
talk about it it's just so strong you
know i don't know if there is a dry eye
after watching something like that it
was katie bryant the mother of dante
wright who served as the prosecution's
first witness
did you see your son's body on the
ground i did
storm says the emotional testimony
affected the entire family i mean it was
so hard for everyone in that room to
watch katie testify for
her children to see her and that kind of
pain
it made it
so hard to watch on multiple levels uh
in the room because it's you know i i am
an attorney on the ground here in
minnesota i know the wright family
really well
and it was already hard to watch katie
in that kind of pain and then to watch
her kids you know sort of experiencing
uh that trauma you know for her and
reliving their feelings about dante
being killed
um it was probably one of the more
emotional things that i think
um i i you know i've ever seen bryant
you were interviewed by law enforcement
and you had an attorney
named jeff storms representing you
correct correct in cross-examination the
defense pressed bryant for information
about her attorneys even calling out
storms by name you expect that when you
walk into any room that if there's a
statement given at some point someone's
going to point out that you know you had
a civil rights or personal injury lawyer
the defense
is you know starting with its attack
on dante and so it's a very challenging
thing to watch a family go through
rounding out the first week of the trial
storms tells me the right and bryant
family are impressed with the
prosecution so far and have full faith
in its case moving forward for long
crime network i'm sierra gillespie
thank you for that interview sierra and
of course great reporting as always
still ahead on law and crime daily the
supreme court makes a contentious ruling
on the texas abortion ban but first a
guilty verdict and an end to the jesse
smollett hoax attack trial in chicago
our legal analyst explains what's next
for the former empire actor
[Music]
hi this is dan abrams with exciting news
for all of our law and crime followers
on youtube you can now get the live lawn
crime network with youtube tv for all of
your daily live trial coverage legal
news expert analysis and original true
crime programs subscribe to youtube tv
today and then locate law and crime in
the channel guide and for only 1.99 a
month you can add the network to your
bundle watch lawn crime every day with
youtube tv we put you in the jury box
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily an
illinois jury finds former empire actor
jesse smallett guilty of hiring two men
to help him stage a hate crime attack
jurors found smallett guilty of five of
six counts of felony disorderly conduct
for filing false police reports claiming
he was attacked by two men who used
anti-gay and racial slurs smallhead also
claimed the men placed a noose around
his neck and poured bleach on him the
two men who are brothers testified
smolette paid them to help him with a
hoax to help his career smollett took
the stand and denied the claim he will
be sentenced next year and faces
possible prison time smallett's lawyers
say they will appeal
let's bring back l.a county deputy
public defender phillip duvet and terry
austin to discuss this verdict and
what's next for smallette terry it's
seeing smallest testament did not ring
true in the ears of the jurors is this
verdict what you expected after hearing
all of the evidence
absolutely he was one of the most
incredibly
false witnesses i've ever heard his
statements did not ring true to anyone
especially as far as his jury is
concerned his testimony was inconsistent
he basically knew his perpetrator how
are you going to know the perpetrators
and then claim that they attacked you
he beat you know 3 500 to stage the
incident he said the news was on the
whole time then he literally took it off
and put it back on he didn't cooperate
with authorities he wouldn't give the
authorities his phone he didn't give the
authorities you know any medical
information so basically he
looked really bad on the stand and i
think the jury realized that every
single thing he said was a lie and they
found him guilty on five of the six
counts yeah that would be that makes
sense based on the verdict philip
smullet is now facing up to three years
in prison as a public defender you have
some experience pleading for the lesser
sentence what's the argument that
smallett shouldn't get jail time here
well first of all i think the
prosecution is hanging their hat on the
fact that they spent a boatload of money
to crack the case
on a personal level and legally speaking
i don't think the cost of prosecution
should ever factor into what sentence a
person gets now having said that from
what i understand jesse has absolutely
no criminal record
being branded a felon for life
oftentimes is punishment enough to have
to go through life and explain to the
world you're a felon sometimes is worse
than doing a little time now on the
other hand he did
cause people to detract whatever
victimhood there could be toward lgbts
and black people
and as a result you know we need to have
something in place to prevent and deter
this behavior in the future i could see
a judge given in 90 days all right we'll
see 90 days i know probation is still on
the table as well but we'll see when
that verdict and the sentence sorry
comes in switching now to federal court
out of arkansas a guilty verdict for
former realities tv star josh duggar for
accessing and downloading child
pornography known for his role in 19
kids and counting duggar was arrested in
april the tlc show was cancelled in 2015
amid duggard's molestation scandal when
a previously sealed police report
revealed that he allegedly improperly
and appropriately touched multiple young
girls including his sisters then in 2019
authorities say they traced child
pornography downloads to duggar's work
i.p address during a bond hearing in may
investigators say duggard had dozens of
photos and videos depicting the sexual
abuse of children as young as toddlers
the defense argued someone else
downloaded the images and videos duggar
now faces up to 40 years in prison and
up to a 500 000 fined his sentencing is
set to happen in a few months with no
date set as of yet
coming up on law and crime daily new
developments in the twisted web of the
murdoch murder mystery
the supreme court makes a contentious
ruling on a strictly texas abortion law
we break down the ruling ahead
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily the
supreme court makes its ruling on a
controversial texas abortion law making
the procedure illegal after six weeks of
pregnancy but justice has also ruled
abortion providers have the right to
challenge this law in federal court
this makes the texas abortion laws the
most restrictive in the nation the law
was put in place on september first in
october united states supreme court
justices heard oral arguments on the
contentious law
this week the supreme court refused to
block the law meaning texas abortions
are not permitted after six weeks often
before women know they are pregnant the
law does not make exceptions for cases
involving rape or incest scotus did rule
however that texas abortion providers
can sue state officials in a federal
court and continue to challenge the ban
back to discuss the supreme court ruling
as l.a county deputy public defender
philip duvet and co-host terry austin
terry skoda seems to be worried about
the enforcement of the law not as much
the merits of abortions what did the
court decide based on the arguments
you know the court blocked anyone from
you know basically they refused to block
the law that texas imposed and it is the
most restrictive in the nation and as
you said after six weeks the you know
women cannot decide to bring an abortion
even if there's rape or incest to me
making the you know abortion law
effective and not saying anything about
what the
providers can do is saying that they can
continue to challenge to me that seems
inconsistent it's a cop-out yeah now
philip where does this leave the law for
abortions in texas
well at this point what it really means
is that uh it's subjecting the aiders
and the bettors if you will to abortions
to civil liability the law remains
intact but what i predict is going to
happen is that people who bring suit are
going to be facing cross complaints
because i believe that this law
conflicts with federal hipaa laws
texas medical privacy and also there's a
state constitutional provision in texas
that just uh provides for texans to be
let alone in their personal and medical
affairs so i think this will create a
boatload of additional litigation
yeah i think the issue of abortion is
still there but the side issues as you
put up there philip are really going to
create a tangled web in texas and of
course we'll peel back that web as it
continues here on law and crime daily
when we come back a former south
carolina attorney faces new charges the
murdoch murder mystery case grows as the
new indictments bring his charges to
nearly 50 in total
welcome back to law and crime daily it's
a case that captured the nation's
attention nearly two decades ago now
convicted wife killer scott peterson is
back in the spotlight he was
re-sentenced wednesday to life in prison
without parole for the murder of his
wife lacey and their unborn son connor
on christmas eve 2002. tv cameras were
not allowed in the courtroom during the
hearing lacey's mother and siblings
spoke telling peterson he quote will
always be their murderer peterson could
get a new trial if a court determines
jeremy's conduct was present peterson's
sister responded to the resentencing
this week and described seeing her
brother once again in the courtroom
seeing scott in the courtroom yesterday
mirrored what i had seen 17 years ago
scott still appears to be vacant and
emotionless
even with the mask on and it was hard to
see the rest of his face
uh i still saw that
yesterday after hearing lacy lacey's
siblings and
her mother speak i realized that
although 17 years have passed
the feelings of complete sadness
loss
and anguish still exist
and in south carolina the twisted web of
the murdoch murder mystery continues to
spin as 21 new charges are handed down
to the disgraced attorney alec murdoch
this now brings the total to 12
indictments and 48 separate charges
stemming from allegations that murdoch
defrauded victims more than 6 million
dollars he is charged with breach of
trust fraudulent intent computer crimes
money laundering and forgery he's also
charged with insurance fraud for
allegedly stealing money from the estate
of gloria statterfield murdoch's
housekeeper who died mysteriously on the
family property in 2018. all this is
just the latest twist in the so-called
murdoch murder mystery in june murdoch's
wife maggie and son paul were found dead
on their family property murdock has
been named a person of interest in the
case but no charges have been filed in
september murdoch claimed he was shot in
the head while changing a flat tire he
later revealed it was all part of a
botched suicide by hire plan meant to
leave remaining son buster with an
insurance payout a bond hearing for
murdoch is scheduled for next week
phillip is it normal and how does it
work for murdoch to be charged with some
crimes one day than 21 more than next
well first of all they had to bring him
in asap to prevent him from reoffending
it seems like every time he turned
around there was new charges that were
being uh unearthed
but what they can do is essentially
bring him in hold him and keep
investigating all the other leads to the
other crimes that they have and perhaps
listen in on jail calls get more
documents start building the case you
know it's not as if they have unlimited
resources to investigate every
allegation and every crime so as they
start to uh solve if you will or crack
each allegation they'll add additional
charges and it's just time consuming the
good news is he's behind bars that he
cannot reoffend assuming he you know
doesn't commit any crimes while in uh
custody yeah we'll see what kind of
insurance fraud he may or may not be
able to get into while in custody terry
48 charges break those down uh the worst
of them for us
maybe he gets some jail time what is
murdoch looking at now going forward
i think the worst of the crimes is the
crime where he is offending these
individual victims versus an insurance
company and the charges are all felonies
he could basically face hundreds of
years in prison and to your point you
know there are 48 charges against this
individual i think there's no question
that he is going to be serving quite a
bit of jail time and the fact that he
created a fraudulent bank account just
to get all of this money it really is a
horrible case he has really gone down
absolutely we'll see how this case goes
thank you for joining us here on law and
crime daily we'll see you next time as
we discuss justice in america
[Music]
[Music]
you